late in the campaign of Gears of War
Marcus Fenix kicks in the front door of
his childhood home the wallpaper is
peeling the furniture is in disarray and
a fine layer of dust blankets every
surface from the ceiling to the floor
returning to a dilapidated family home
serves as a poetic echo of the task at
hand many members of developer the
coalition worked on the original gears
of war and this remaster is the studio's
first release before it launches Gears
of War 4 and although the studio has
created a faithful homage to the game
that started it all they neglected to
clean up a few things in the process
there's a lot of history here a lot of
lies - well you've got some nerve
soldier Gears of War Ultimate Edition
lets you cheat time and travel back to
2006 when you first saw Phoenix skulking
in shadowy jelsa because of the new
resolution Gears of War Ultimate Edition
fills in cracks and polishes paintwork
to preserve our ever so fragile
nostalgia I played Gears of War on Xbox
360 recently and the differences here
are apparent Ultimate Edition removes
the muddy textures shiny faces and bleak
environments of the original replacing
them with detailed landscapes and
brighter hues the coalition remade every
cutscene and even though I've seen them
before the new skin makes it feel like
the first time again
an Ultimate Edition doesn't just change
things on a visual level the original
Gears of War marked the pinnacle of
third-person shooting at its time and in
2015 that cover based combat is still at
the top of its class the campaign still
feels smooth and fluid and I noticed it
right away
Ultimate Edition is also a reminder of
how much I'd forgotten about the first
years the campaign is much more horror
driven than its sequels with haunting
corridors and dim basements giving way
to shrieking monsters emerging from the
ground this is a story about a ragtag
group of heroes long before we saw them
amidst the chaos of an all-out war the
characters don't have too much depth for
them here and mainly serve as vehicles
for the action but the campaign serves
as a reminder of when we first saw them
to have Marcus he'll get over it and
then I jumped a multiplayer and it's 60
FPS all of my muscle memory came back I
hip fired the nation' perfected active
reload times and dodged between cover as
if it were 9 years ago there are two new
game modes here including the
traditional team deathmatch and king of
the hill and they're both welcome
additions to this fluid new incarnation
Gears of War Ultimate Edition doesn't
just look like my nostalgia remembers it
also feels like it too but despite how
great Altima Titian looks and feels it
hasn't completely erased the original
versions blemishes the gears franchise
is always catered to a cooperative
experience and the remaster is no
exception
throughout my time with the campaign my
AI partner Dom Santiago often made
things difficult for me he deliberately
wandered into the shadows when the
objective was to stay in the light he
walked into the path of my gun obscuring
my view numerous times and often when my
progress relied on the AI nothing
happened and I had to reload my check
one
the latter was a frequent problem
throughout my campaign the first Gears
isn't always obvious about where to go
next and the remaster has kept that
aspect intact
i reloaded checkpoints a total of five
times before I reached act 5
all because cutscenes wouldn't trigger
or a wall wouldn't crumble on cue it's
one thing to lose progress because of
death it's another to lose it because of
design errors but despite these flaws
Gears of War Ultimate Edition is still a
faithful remaster of a nine year old
game
the return trip might reveal a few more
cracks than we remember but it also
serves as a shield for our nostalgia and
as remakes go that's worth noting
the or
do this
you